please tell me that you are not one of
these people who say we can't celebrate
Christmas right now like I believe
as if I could I thank you
thank you okay so I'm
actually really love this question
because I've been starting to see some
Christmas stuff pop up as we all have
been and I have a little bit it has
let's let's quote Mary condo here is
that her name it has spark Joy because I
have two little girls that are three and
one just turned five and time is it's
going too fast it really is I could
honestly I could get emotional about it
right now it's going too fast and I
wanted to slow down so if the Christmas
season could like drag out a little bit
more yes I'm off for it so that's why
we're doing holiday collection in
November we starting it off right
starting it off right what was it you're
getting my Christmas tree I think we're
doing like the Thanksgiving Christmas
tree this year I think so do it even
before really
it's just insane oh my God your girls
would blow their mind would like blow
their Lids if you came and brought a
Christmas tree next week well I yeah
yeah I'd blow my own mind if I did that
because they're heavy and it's hard to
no
um it's just gonna take prep I think
Thanksgiving is maybe a yeah so when do
you still start like having inspiration
for the holiday line then since we're
super weird because you have inspiration
you have to have inspiration for the
holiday line in like
July
of the year before so you're like I
don't know and thankfully I work with
you know this amazing designer
um co-designer at New York and Company
and they kind of are they're all over
Trends because I'm I don't really I'm
not a I don't follow the trend so much I
kind of follow just what I love and I
follow
um just kind of I go by by Feeling by
emotion like you know uh but yeah so I
have to start designing for holidays in
July which is like you know doesn't feel
right so I turn up the AC well I would
anyway it's July and I you know
play some Christmas music we really did
did you yeah we did and then I was kind
of like okay red leopard I don't know
hey you look very holiday-ish with a
little Flair do you guys have holiday
traditions at home do you
um we we do
um you just made me think about my my
brother who I who I lost three years ago
when I was um pregnant with my little
one but one of the holiday traditions we
used to have was that at like
Thanksgiving dinner he would like roast
everybody which was so fun and
um and not fun too because it'll he'd
always cross that line so that was that
was a fun one we haven't done it since
uh since he passed oh we go big we go
Christmas Latin like Cubans like to do
the night before like we don't we we
kind of split the the American and the
Cuban you know what I mean because we
have the big dinner on the 24th noche
buena we have the a big big dinner and
then Cubans like to open their presents
at night but we kind of Americanized it
because Christmas morning is so special
yeah so we do presents at Christmas
nothing like those faces those little
faces on Christmas morning
yeah that's special
Brian's birthday how do you celebrate
oh my gosh
um I'm doing something really fun but
I'm obviously not gonna say
okay so I mean because well it's a
surprise I don't go big
um but I go you go thoughtful yeah I
like it yeah I don't know yeah that's
better yeah I don't go big but I I go uh
profound oh and um yeah emotional you
have these little ones and they're
precious but you have to figure out now
you're a working mom so how do you take
that work that style that you have to
have as a mom and transition it into
what I need to be mom when I need to be
at work how does that style go oh that's
why it came out with the line of
t-shirts a couple years ago I didn't
yeah I didn't do t-shirts before
um in the line and a couple years ago I
was like guys uh we need to serve in
some more casuals and how about some
T-shirts and it was literally the first
one was uh it said Cuba Libre which
means no obviously
um but uh but so we came out with some
Cuban theme and then Miami theme
t-shirts but that really that's my day
today for reels I'm not really wearing
this red leopard at home okay so let's
talk about the collection then let's
talk about some favorite pieces and what
like is your favorite piece if you know
we're gonna have a date night yes well I
think you know the red leopard of it all
I really do love this dress because it
has it's so great because it's just like
you know you're wearing red leopard you
know it's all you need you really don't
need to say anything else I just want it
all okay take it that's it take it off
and we're wrapped I'm starting bodysuits
I'm starting here because I love her I
love her and I love that you say her
because I call all my dresses
so I love her and she's married
is she not Maria I think she's more of a
Maria
um but I love a cinch at the waist I
think that's always really important
with all my clothes I always have the
option at least like with this dress
um I love a sweater set I just love a
sweater set I wish that people could
feel this because it's yummy it's just
so so soft it's so soft this is a great
knit and then the bodysuits when I was
telling you a little bit about the
bodysuit I started the line with the
bodysuit sorry I didn't mean to cover
your face so I started the line
so I started the collection with
bodysuits six years ago because this is
what I lived in in high school not this
one but I just was like a bodysuit girl
anyway and now even as a g-string with
her body suits I do do because this is
what women want yeah this is is what I
always I always ask women I read all my
comments on Instagram well I ignore some
of them but I read most of them that
have to do with the clothes and women
are like please we want the the g-string
bodysuit I prefer the full but that's
just me but well I give the women they
want junk so we don't like the
indentation
look back here I hear you and then here
we go a little off the shoulder and I
just thank you for seeing her yeah I
love her because look at the little
polka dots but also like I just I I love
a sweater I love it I don't have a Chic
pant and this cigarette pant is and I
know it's obvious to go red for the
holidays but it's the holidays I can't I
want to Sparkle I want to go red I want
to like you know give it a little
glitter
come on pink I mean really she's so
beautiful and great on any skin tone
this sleeve three quarters yeah that
sleep is big I know I don't like my
elbows I think I have really weird
does not like her elbows I don't like my
elbows never did every other part of
y'all perfect
my elbows are covered tonight hahaha you
can't see them
um but they're just they're always like
they look dirty they always look dirty
and and then dirty elbows at 45 is not
not cute right now at least you know
okay listen how do you elbows yeah dirty
elbows in general but dirty elbows at 45
is not worse yeah so can I come back to
this for a second because the word that
comes to my mind when I see this is Lux
I feel like that I could be like in
Aspen in front of a fire in this okay
like sipping hot cocoa so what's one of
your favorite pieces if you're gonna
have a girls night out oh I think
um you know I this is I would do this
without the tie gotcha you know just
kind of like that flowy I like flowy
yeah I like an all-you-can-eat dress you
know that's what I call this dress yes
so I think I'd go you know yeah if
you're going to go on a red carpet
what's your favorite well red carpets my
God I haven't done red carpets in so
long and um I kind of you know we miss
you by the way oh that's very sweet I
don't miss you
and I say that with all the love in the
world
you as in the general you know yes yes
of course you I miss your face your
beautiful face but uh they're stressful
if I can skip one uh I do what would it
take to get you back is to get you back
on a red carpet what's the kind of roll
that that could bring you back uh I
don't know but I'm I'm really honestly
now now I'm now that they're getting a
little bit bigger yeah and now that I
see that they are actually you and I
were talking about this before the
cameras were on but they're actually you
know they're going to school and they're
having a bit more autonomy
um so they don't they of course they
need me they're still little but I'm
starting to feel more freedom to kind of
be like okay what am I open to now
um so you know it just takes a special
kind of project okay so the closet door
isn't completely closed it is not closed
completely no it is not I'm actually
excited to find something do you see
your fashion style kind of influence
your girls or are they figuring out
their own style because they're so like
they're so free you know and it's so
beautiful and I never like I don't push
like dresses I don't push anything on
them and then I'm just like you want to
wear you want to wear your jammies to
the market wear your jammies to the
market as long as you're like not gonna
be you know you need if you need a coat
or if you need to be you know like
appropriately dressed for the climate
you can do whatever you want and now
they have their you know Halloween
costumes um my little girl wore her uh
puppy Halloween costume to class today
and I was like why not real full I used
to wear long johns and boxers like long
jump with boxes or my mother would be
like ah and but she's just Freedom
that's so great because really when can
you you can't I mean you can do that
today but really you can't have you
walked into your closet yet and they're
in there playing dress-up no they like
wearing my shoes they like wearing my
shoes which is which is is cool but I'm
like okay you know you feel a little
like I just they're still babies but
they do and they bet they're good
balancers so I was thinking get them
stilts like turn it into a craft you
know turn it into something make some
money
get a trade
I loved your Instagram post when you
were posting about needing trying to
figure out a way to sneak away for a
second if you have some me time what
does me time look like when you get that
meantime this is it yeah no it's kind of
true work has become me time which is
kind of fun again
um but me time is uh you know I'm kind
of a sucker for a new I love taking
advantage of like a new kind of any kind
of facial treatment any kind of um
appeal a um radio frequency treatment I
like that that sounds good right yeah
because it hurts and I have a theory if
it hurts it's going to have better
results I don't know if that's a real
well the skin of yours is delicious so
whatever you're doing we need step by
step you uh
I have an amazing woman her name is
Mariana Vergara she's just amazing and
she works at Blush in Beverly Hills and
really it's about finding that person
that you click with and that knows your
skin and um I don't know I just I find
that like fun as I get older it's kind
of like oh wait I can take advantage of
technology and all the fun stuff we have
available keep your eyes on the road
Cowboy so you were in Too Fast Too
Furious I was could could like a
franchise like that could they entice
you back because that franchise is crazy
it is crazy
um and it's ongoing like forever and
ever I know I don't I don't know
cardi B is in this next one coming up oh
amazing advice for her venturing into
that franchise
she's I need advice from her she doesn't
need it but
um wow that's gonna be fun that's gonna
be fun yeah do you have it by because
she's starting to really dip her toe in
to acting yeah and now she's getting
into that franchise like that's so huge
do you have any advice for her anything
that you I mean really I think cardi B's
just I think she's good she's got it
right she really does she's um I've just
she's the best you've never reprise Your
Role you'd never I mean and you know I
just feel like in a way for me just my
personality not about that specific
um
project
um I feel like kind of when I'm done
with something I'm kind of done with it
yeah but who knows but that's just how I
am in general
I'm just like I did that cool okay what
else move it along what I realized is I
have been screwing up for years yes
saying your name wrong years I mean okay
so so give me a tutorial how are we
really supposed to say well it is
actually my fault because I wanted to be
very like Americanized like in junior
high school and high school I was like
it's Eva right so that was those years
so that's okay
then like in like my 20s I was like well
I'm really like it's more of Ava really
you know like Eva would be that's not my
name
um so I went through the Avery years and
I think now I'm finally starting to
correct people like it's really Eva it's
really Eva because I'm Cuban right I'm
Cuban not Eva it's not Ava it's Eva Eva
you say that beautifully by the way
perfect Ava Ava and if you want to like
be sweet or like you know you could say
Evita Evita yeah that's like old like
little Eva oh it's cute
but I honestly don't care here so if you
end up calling me Eva that's totally
fine no Eva that's what I'm saying it
like that
was on fire my mom says it a little
differently yeah my mom says it with a
little weight you know
yep there you go are you sure you're not
Cuban I listening exactly I will take it
all
[Music]
thank you